hi hi guys hello you took chairs Louis
and our friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
32nd episode of dirty chance tricks in
this episode I'm going to show you some
of the devastating and wonderful tricks
in the slough defense from the black
perspective the opening arises after the
following water that is d4 d5 c4 and now
black support the center with the moves
c6 and it doesn't matter whether you up
and continue with Knight to c3 or Knight
to f3 let's say in this game why
continue with the move Knight to c3 and
after Knight to f6 we reach to the
pretty much starting position of the
slower defense
now the first trick I want to show you
is when white continue here with the
move III which is in fact very much
popular at the higher level before I
move on there is one point I like to
mention here that there's a difference
between slough and Flemish loud offense
in Slough defense generally black prefer
this Bishop either on F Phi or g4 before
he closed the center where in semi
slough black plays the move he seeks
immediately and preserve this bishop to
safeguard the b7 square ok black
continue obviously with Bishop to a5 and
one of the main line continue from here
onwards that is Bishop to d3 the bishop
captures d3 win captures d3 and now the
move e six so black is more than happy
to get rid of his bad bishop and
creating this live square pawn chain
which gives him a rock-solid position
why continue with the move Knight to f3
Knight B to d7 Castle on the Kings side
and now here my recommendation is black
should continue with the move Bishop to
b4 obviously this move is very tricky
and the most popular response from here
is Bishop to d2 which creates the first
trap if black is not careful enough for
example if black foolishly Castle at
this point then after Knight captures B
Phi White obtain a winning position a
sample line can roll like this Bishop
captures d2 Knight captures f6 check
Knight captures f6 and now Queen
captures d2 and after all white emerge
with an extra pole and a wonderful
position so obviously black should not
fall for this and instead of that here
black should continue with the move if I
so protecting the Bishop naturally what
is going to hit this Bishop with the
move a3 with the tempo and Bishop drop
back to the e7 afterwards the most
popular choice are either efore or b3
followed by E for
but against both of them black has a
devastating technical blow now if you
open and place the movie for immediately
here then I have a dead simple line in
the PGN which will give you a very good
idea
how blacks should obtain an advantage
and in fact play for the win the more I
want to consider in this video is b3
which is very natural wife's idea is if
black capture the c-4 pole then he wants
to recapture with the pawn and
consolidate his center so initially
black has to avoid this and castle on
the kingside and after this what can be
the more neutral then playing the movie
for grabbing every single space in the
center and asking black what are you
doing well yes of course it's a pretty
sight for the white except there is one
problem that black is winning after this
wonderful moon so now black is
sacrificing the whole light and white is
of light should take it otherwise the e4
pawn will draw and in fact the position
so let's see what black is up to after
this devastating piece sacrifice he kept
to c4 and now black reveal his nasty
idea with D caps evil attacking to peace
once again white response is force white
has to take the Queen and after rook F
to d8 you can see the vital point by the
black that is black is still attacking
to pcs and white cannot see both of them
if Knight captures a foe here then the
simplest is you take this knife and
after Bishop to e3 and Bishop captures C
Phi after the whole sequence black
emerge with an extra pawn so that can't
be good for the white so the most
popular response at this position is
Bishop to e3 but I don't think so this
resolved any problem by white camp
because after he captures f3g catches f3
and the move rook to d3 already black
has given white a double born and
attacking on the night
now the illustrate the danger in this
position I like to show you one of my
rapid game from this position where my
opponent was 2100 rated plus and he
continued with the move Knight to e4
because I guess if I foolishly take this
b3 porn then after rook to beavin rook
captures rook captures so you can see
that rook is attacking on b7 and now
black cannot defend with the move rook
to b8 because after Bishop to f4 the
resulting position is favourable to the
right side but of course black is in an
order to capture this pawn so instead of
that I continue with a stronger move
that is Knight to h5 so now indeed I
have stopped the move Bishop to f4 and
black is all set to capturing the b3
pawn now it does not matter whether
white continue here with rook to be one
or the move before because more or less
it leads to the same scenario in the
game he continued with the movie 4 but
after fi white is in a great difficulty
the game continues with the move Knight
to b6 attacking the rook rook to D H and
now why C is nothing better than
capturing this pawn but then comes f4
hitting the bishop the bishop to c1 and
now Bishop captures C Phi even though
material is balanced you can see the
pathetic position of the white pieces
not only it has a two set of double
pawns but his pieces are hardly
considered as an active in this game
after few moves that easily converted
the full point
the second trick happens in Queen to see
to radiation
we're not only white protect the sea for
porn but also stopping Bishop to fi idea
now pay special attention here because
the game I'm about to show you where
2400 plus rated I am fall into this
trick and immediately get lost position
in the opening and not only he time to
time many title players are falling into
so there are every chance that you might
get in one of your game at this position
black who is a GM continue with the MU T
capture Sifu and after Quinn capture
Sifu now he develop his Bishop with
Bishop purify so black has given slight
concession by giving up the center in
order to complete his pistol movement
okay
the mainline runs with the MU G 3 e six
Bishop to G to Knight B to d7 castle on
the kingside Bishop to e7 Knight to c3
and castle on the kingside we're here
white should continue with the move
either III all rook to even where game
is completely balanced but many times
and as happened in this game why I
decided to continue with the move rook
to d1 if he doesn't know the theory very
well this move looks very natural as why
has a very simple idea that is night
which for attacking the bishop and when
the bishop move he wants to continue
with the movie for defy open up the
center and get a wonderful position
sometimes in chess we think too far and
missed out the immediate disaster and
this is one of the clearcase before i
move on i like you to pause this video
and find out a move which will
immediately gives black of in engage
okay I hope you find this wonderful move
Bishop to c2 and black is winning on the
10th amor game the idea behind this cute
move is now this white queen doesn't
have any escape squared so for example
if white continued to save his route
with rook - even then up tonight to b6
the white baby is trapped in the center
of the ball amazing right
so accordingly white cannot move the
rook and the majority of the cases
continue here with the move III
but after Bishop captures rook and
Knight captures Bishop just within 12
moves black NAB the exchange and in fact
with the accurate play can easily
convert the full point I have attached
rest of the game in the PG n which will
give you a very good idea how black
should continue from here onwards
the third and the final trick I want to
consider in the Geller foolish gambit
which is one of the grace you've set up
by white and it arises after the
following order that is Knight to c3 D
catch a c4 and now white gambit the pawn
for grabbing the center with the MU evil
okay
black initially defend the c4 with the
move b5 and now the mainline continues
with the following order that is ePHI
Knight to d5 a for e 6a captures B Phi
Knight captures c3 attacking the Queen
so white response is force be kept to
see three and now black get his spawn
with sea captain's b5 right main idea is
to play Knight to g5 and after Bishop to
b7 if you check this position in online
database you will find out that here the
most popular response is Queen to h5 and
it is very logical as well because after
the move Queen to h5 white is hitting to
sports and blacken or defend both of
them so the question is what to do well
as usual I am going to suggest a very
tricky move in this position and that is
Queen to d7 so not only black is
protecting the f7 but setting up a
devastating trigger now here black
should continue with the move Bishop to
e2 but not many of the opponent are
going to resist with this continuation
that is Knight captures at 7 and it
looks very logical because now white is
threatening to way attack that is either
Knight to f6 or night to f8 and black
cannot Perry both of them and after all
white regain his pawn back with a
wonderful position and yes indeed it's
true except one problem that white is
straightaway fallen into the black
Camp tricky zone start with the move
Knight to c6
so now White has few choices but against
each of them Black has some wonderful
tactical shots the first move I want to
consider is Knight to f6 which looks
very natural because it's [ __ ] king
and queen and after blacks force reply
that is G captures f6 why can simply win
an exchange with a great position well
nope it's not that simple because black
has this wonderful shot boom hahahaha
Black is sacrificing more material to
get White King which is stuck in the
center if rook to a2 then Knight to b3
is a very strong reply and I have
covered that line in the PG n so the
natural question arises what happens if
white accept this piece well after this
black will continue with the move Queen
captures d4 attacking the rook rook to
a2 and now Castle on the Queen side and
suddenly from nowhere black obtained of
winning position black has two threads
which cannot be easily defended and to
illustrate the poison in this position I
like to show you one of my blitz game
where my opponent which is a candidate
master continue with the move rook to d2
but black response is very obvious
Bishop to b4 not only pinning the roof
but attacking the Queen my opponent
defended with Queen to f6 but just one
move Queen to e1 and white realize that
he is in a big-time danger he continued
with the move hint we - so unpinning the
rocker but after the following sequence
that is Bishop captures d2 Bishop
captures d2 and the star mu c3 and white
simply resign the simple reason is y
cannot move the
as after Queen to Devon white King can
hardly survive in the open border so
it's very clear that Knight to f6 leads
to disaster zone for the white so in the
database more than 10 games continue
from here Knight captures a fit and it's
very logical as well white is exchanging
pieces let's say if rook captures edge
fire then Knight captures d7 and the
resulting position with two bishop I
think White has slightly upper hand but
let me tell you one thing that in this
position black has one of the most
amazing tactical shot in the slough
defense and I will give you some time
think about it
how you are going to continue from black
which will obtain a winning position did
you find it
let's see the stunning move is Pam when
first time I see this more I said hang
on what's going on man his black is
going nuts well of course it's not and
the more you look at this position more
you realize that after this wonderful
Queen sacrifice pike position is
completely collapsing if go into f3 then
Queen catches Aoife is a very strong
reply so mainly there are two frequent
replies over here the first more I want
to consider is Queen catches h8 which is
not a good move the simple reason is
after Queen capture c3 white cannot even
think about going on the default as
after castle the game will not last long
so the obvious move over here is Bishop
to d2 afterwards black will enjoy this
King downs that is king - E - Knight to
d4 King to e3 Knight to f5 King to f4
Queen check King to g5 Queen captures B
to check f4 and now it's a matter of
choice which mu you want to consider
King g7 and Queen to d8 both gives
winning attack to the black so the
biggest question arises what happens if
you open and take this Queen
well after that obviously black is going
to recapture the Queen and now that
night on f8 is completely trapped so
white has to forcefully go for this line
that is Knight captures a6f captures
ecigs and now in the view of d4 pawn is
hanging white responses force he has to
continue with the move Bishop to e3 now
to illustrate the ideas and the plants
in the middle game from this position I
like to show you one of my game against
a feed a master where I continue with
the move rook to edge for attacking d4
if g3 then rook captures v4 is a very
strong reply so my opponent naturally
defended with the move castle on the
Queen side but this move awakened all
the attacking prospects from the black
perspective here I continue with the
move Knight to before he responded with
Bishop to e2 his idea is if I capture
the g2 pawn then his rook is going to be
active where the move rook to JP so I
decided to avoid it and continue with a
strong move Bishop to b4 my simple idea
is I want to exchange the light square
bishop and then roll down Queen side
maturity and as you will see in this
game it turns out very well
my opponent continued with them where 3
I played Bishop to d3 he captured my
bishop I capture with the night it's a
check so he responded with him to d2 and
now here comes my plan before so there
are not one not two but three time bombs
are going down to the end of the rule
and white has to do a hell of a job to
stop them it is bonded with rook to e1 I
continue my pawn march with a 5 then
after the following continuation that is
rook to a 2
a four ash tree a tree rook h2 even and
now the final piece of the puzzle King
to f7 which creates a deadly strategic
plan that is I want to play a rook to H
file and then join my other roof into
the party and then continue with the
movie fo and white is hopeless to stop
this plan after few moves Black has
comfortably win this game and you can
check it out in the pgl well I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful tricks in
the slough defense from the black
perspective thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care